to present the award for the best
director of the year
sunny Italy's great gift to smoggy
California mr. feel Lauren
nice to have you darling thank you very
much Bob and I would like to thank the
Academy for the recognition they're
giving this year to Italian artist Anna
Magnani Victoria de sica and Federico
Fellini well I guess you have to be a
tagging in wild as the wind Anna manana
got it an anthony quinn got nominated
the poor little sheep didn't get
anything she works so hard to well
that's show business
Sophia I understand you just finished a
comedy with Cary Grant why don't we go
to Italy and make a picture together you
know in one of those picturesque towns
on the Mediterranean like in all the
Italian movies windblown realistic a
light in the darkness the shadows of a
couple you and me making love in the
beach oh if you just walk out we could
even get a camera catch on fast honey
but I already made that picture at the
envelope please where is it the envelope
I have been before I had me scared to
death I wrote the nomination for the
best achievement in directing our David
Ling for the Bridge on the River Kwai
Mac Robson for Peyton Place Joshua Logan
for sayonara Sidney Lumet for 12 Angry
Men and Billy Wilder for witness for the
prosecution Oh gah the Bridge on the
River Kwai
when we were sweating away in the
jungles of salon I never dreamt that
bridge of ours would carry me here to
Hollywood for the first time let alone
to this moment on this stage I am very
very deeply honored and thank you very
much
you